[Música]
tercer día de enfrentamientos entre las
fuerzas israelíes y el grupo hamas que
dejan ya un saldo de 65 palestinos y 7
israelíes fallecidos el primer ministro
de israel benjamin netanyahu rechazó la
propuesta de rusia de un alto el fuego
mientras que el presidente de eeuu joe
biden afirmó que israel tiene derecho a
defenderse
nueva jornada de paro nacional en
colombia y jornada número 15 de
manifestaciones ciudadanas pacíficas que
estuvieron marcadas por el regreso a sus
resguardos de los indígenas que estaban
en la ciudad de cali y también por el
encuentro que sostuvo el presidente iván
duque con un grupo de estudiantes
tenemos los detalles desde las ciudades
de bogotá y cannes
y en una votación secreta la bancada
republicana en la cámara de
representantes- expulsó del liderazgo
del partido a la representante del
isstey ni por rechazar los señalamientos
del ex presidente de trompas del
supuesto fraude en las elecciones
presidenciales y también por criticar la
insurrección del pasado 6 de enero
tenemos más información desde la ciudad
de washington
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar en medio
oriente donde continúan los ataques
entre las fuerzas israelíes y también
las milicias palestinas en la peor
ofensiva desde el año 2014
los intercambios de cohetes y también
los ataques aéreos dejan 65 palestinos
fallecidos entre ellos 16 menores de
edad mientras que del lado israelí las
víctimas mortales llegan ya a 7 la
escalada de las tensiones llegan tras
las protestas de palestinos durante el
fin de semana en rechazo a los posibles
desalojos en la ciudad de jerusalén que
terminaron con enfrentamientos con las
fuerzas israelíes el consejo de
seguridad de la organización de las
naciones unidas se reunió de emergencia
o sea reunirá este miércoles para hacer
frente a la crisis el presidente de eeuu
joe biden
habló con el primer ministro de israel
benjamin netanyahu y estas fueron sus
palabras
mi expectativa y esperanza es que esto
termine más temprano que tarde pero
israel tiene derecho a defenderse de los
cohetes lanzados hacia su territorio
y entretanto el primer ministro de
israel decretó el estado de urgencia en
la ciudad del lote que es muy cerca a la
ciudad de tel aviv debido a las
manifestaciones de los árabes residentes
en esa zona las manifestaciones
comenzaron como solidaridad a los
palestinos de jerusalén y de la franja
de gaza y terminaron en enfrentamientos
escenarios similares tuvieron lugar
también en otras ciudades de población
palestino israelís
80.000 habitantes de los cuales 23.000
son árabes y una presencia policial
reforzada la ciudad objetivo de un
ataque de misil desde gaza que dejó dos
muertos es del escenario de
enfrentamientos violentos entre judíos y
árabes una violencia que llevó al primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu a declarar
el estado de urgencia atacan a los
ciudadanos a los policías queman casas
coches sinagogas es evidente que no
podemos aceptarlo
ningún país lo haría definitivamente
nosotros no hace días que la minoría
árabe israelí algunos de los cuales
prefieren denominarse palestinos nativos
expresan su cólera el lunes una
manifestación estalló tras la muerte de
un manifestante árabe a manos de un
judío israelí la situación terminó en
enfrentamientos vehículos y comercios
terminaron quemados igual que sinagogas
y un cementerio musulmán en otras
ciudades llamadas mixtas también
estallaron enfrentamientos como en un
mal fama cerca de haifa o en acre la
policía de israel asegura haber detenido
decenas de personas y habla de eventos
sin precedentes lugar aves israelíes o
palestinos nativos son descendientes de
los palestinos que se quedaron en sus
tierras tras la fundación de israel en
1948 representan cerca de un 20% de la
población pero dicen sentirse tratados
como ciudadanos de segunda
décimo quinta jornada de manifestaciones
en colombia una vez más los ciudadanos
salieron a las calles a pedir una
condena más firme en contra de la
violencia policial y también para
reclamar por las políticas que terminen
con la profunda desigualdad en el país
cientos de artistas obreros
sindicalistas y también vendedores
informales se tomaron las calles para
expresar sus reclamos al presidente iván
duque el mandatario de los colombianos
se reunió con diferentes sectores
convocantes a este paro e hizo un
llamado al diálogo un diálogo en el que
no todos se sienten representados
el presidente iván duque intenta
controlar un nuevo día de paro con una
nueva jornada de diálogo un día después
de anunciar acceso gratuito a la
educación universitaria técnica y
tecnológica para los sectores más pobres
de la sociedad durante el segundo
semestre de 2021 el mandatario se reunió
con jóvenes para intentar buscar una
salida a la crisis social sin embargo
muchos de los manifestantes no se
sienten representados por quienes están
en la mesa de conversaciones y piden que
sus voces sean escuchadas y es que los
colombianos siguen exigiendo acciones
concretas en contra de la brutalidad
policial así como una serie de políticas
que eliminen la profunda desigualdad
social en el país suramericano que lo
que podemos observar hoy es que lo que
están haciendo es un juego con el pueblo
colombiano el día de mañana va a haber
una reunión con todos los comités de
todos los puntos de la ciudad de
santiago de cali en la cual vamos a
sacar el folleto y la petición que vamos
a hacer al gobierno nacional y estatal
para que el día viernes tengamos una
reunión con el señor duque duque
prometió investigar denuncias de abuso
policial durante los 15 días de marchas
pero sigue sin ser contundente respecto
al accionar de las fuerzas
es injusto
y señalar a todo aquel que se expresa
pacíficamente en las calles
como un vándalo o como un terrorista o
como un criminal eso no es justo no
procede no tiene lugar
como también es injusto
generalizar
el comportamiento de todos los miembros
de la fuerza pública la defensoría del
pueblo informó que 42 personas han
muerto en las dos semanas de paro y que
168 personas están desaparecidas la ong
local temblores registra 40 muertes por
violencia policial y al menos 1956 casos
de violencia física así como 12 casos de
violencia sexual y vamos a conocer cómo
está la situación en colombia en esta
nueva jornada de paro nacional con
nuestros periodistas destacados en la
ciudad de cali bogotá epicentro de las
principales manifestaciones vamos a
comenzar en cali en el suroccidente de
colombia allí se encuentra luís muñoz o
yo hice muy buenas tardes para usted
allí en la ciudad de cali y cuál es el
balance de esta nueva jornada de paro
allí en la capital del valle del cauca
que contó con la retirada de los
indígenas que estaban allí en esta
ciudad
ambiente festivo sant y un ambiente muy
diferente que el que ha habido en las
últimas semanas en la ciudad de cali
miles de personas salieron a los puntos
de concentración que han estado
bloqueando la ciudad y el lugar de la
violencia ha habido un clima de respeto
y tranquilidad y también de festividad y
es que hoy también se ha conmemorado la
marcha de la minga que ha estado desde
bien entrada la semana pasada aquí
apoyando los diferentes puntos de
concentración y se ha marchado
acompañada por la comisión de la verdad
y también por las naciones unidas- una
marcha que han dicho que es por
cuestiones de seguridad después de que
el pasado domingo tuvieran un encuentro
con manifestantes en los que había
civiles armados que les dispararon
dejando una decena de heridos la minga
se ha concentrado especialmente en
puerto resistencia que es uno de los
puntos clave de concentración aquí en la
ciudad de cali y allí han sido aclamada
por una centenar varios centenares de
personas al grito de gracias minga con
la marcha la minga a sus territorios del
cauca que da preocupación entre los
manifestantes que nos han confesado la
primera
que con la marcha de la minga quedan
desprotegidos y que no saben qué va a
pasar con la acción policial en los
próximos días
louis ya veíamos en el reportaje previo
que el presidente avanza en las
negociaciones con diferentes sectores
que están convocando a este paro o
sectores que no se sienten representados
en la jornada de hoy se reunió con un
grupo de estudiantes que dijeron a qué
conclusiones llegar
si como bien dices santi está aquí el
presidente duque por segunda jornada
realizando diferentes reuniones la choco
la alcaldía con la gobernación y como
dices con diferentes sectores que apoyan
el paro hoy lo ha hecho con un grupo de
estudiantes y lo que ha dicho en general
es que quiere hacer un pacto de juventud
con toda la sociedad sin embargo con los
manifestantes que hemos hablado hoy
también han mostrado preocupación y es
que hoy se han ido a reunir con el
ministro de defensa cuando esperaban
reunirse con el presidente iván duque
estos manifestantes nos han dicho que
los 25 puntos de bloqueo que hay en la
ciudad se han organizado en en una única
unidad y que mañana se van a juntar para
hacer un pliego de reivindicaciones y
esperan el viernes poder reunirse con el
presidente y bando que para desencallar
la situación
louis muchas gracias por este completo
reporte desde la ciudad de cali en el
suroccidente de colombia nos vamos ahora
hasta bogotá que también fue escenario
de manifestaciones hay hubo diferentes
puntos de la capital colombiana en donde
hubo problemas con la movilidad también
pero el balance tal parece que es
positivo juan cuál es el balance
entonces de esta jornada de paro
la capital colombiana
es un balance positivo del cual es
reflejo lo que está ocurriendo ahora
mismo en la plaza de bolívar aquí en el
centro de bogotá este escenario es un
escenario que hemos visto pocas veces
durante los últimos días de protestas
aquí en bogotá ha sido muy difícil ver
una congregación de personas tan grandes
que lleguen a esta hora cuando ya
comienza a entrar la noche en bogotá sin
que haya ningún tipo de enfrentamiento o
choque la presencia de la publicidad es
prácticamente nula al igual que la del
escuadrón antidisturbios la tónica es la
misma que hemos visto desde que
comenzamos a hacer este cubrimiento en
horas de la mañana una marcha masiva
pacífica en este caso quienes están aquí
en su mayoría en la plaza de bolívar son
sobre todo jóvenes que como mayor
incidente protagonizar una toma de la
estatua de simón bolívar que da nombre a
esta plaza siendo eso el mayor incidente
de lo que ha sido esta jornada masiva y
pacífica
-juan sin embargo algunos puntos de la
capital colombiana están registrando
problemas en la movilidad problemas para
desplazarse
largo y ancho de la ciudad y también hay
preocupación porque la capacidad de las
unidades de cuidado intensivo allí por
el cob y 19 están llegando ya al límite
pero a esta hora sobre todo cuando
aquellas personas que no han participado
de este paro y que han tenido una
jornada laboral vuelven a regresar a sus
hogares en una ciudad con más de 7
millones de personas hay problemas de
movilidad aquí en el centro también en
el norte donde hay otra protesta también
de estudiantes algunos de ellos también
protestando de manera masiva siendo eso
los mayores son muy grandes altercados
los dos mayores puntos de concentración
que están obstaculizando el tráfico en
lo que se refiere al transmilenio que es
el sistema de transporte masivo de
bogotá hasta esta hora opera solamente
en uno de esos tramos la alcaldesa de
bogotá claudia lópez pidió que fuera
ésta una jornada pacífica y así la que
ella misma calificó que era una jornada
pacífica y una de sus peticiones era de
que esta marcha fuera terminando cuando
entrara la noche como está ocurriendo
ahora días antes y ella claudia lópez
había hecho un pedido de auxilio para la
población de bogotá teniendo en cuenta
que se ha llegado al 96% de la ocupación
de las camas de cuidados
graciasjuan por este reporte desde
bogotá la capital colombiana vamos ahora
hasta eeuu la bancada republicana en la
cámara de representantes expulsó del
liderazgo del partido a la conservadora
lista
jamie en una votación es secreta la
representante fue castigada por no
aceptar las falsas declaraciones del ex
presidente de donald trump quien afirmó
que el partido demócrata ganó las
elecciones presidenciales del 2020 de
manera fraudulenta y también porque
criticó los ataques del capitolio del
pasado 6 de enero
cheney es hija del ex vicepresidente de
eeuu dick cheney y seguirá siendo
representante del congreso de eeuu por
el estado de wyoming previamente
cristóbal vázquez nuestro corresponsal
en la ciudad de washington nos daba más
detalles sobre lo sucedido en el
siguiente reporte
luís cheney hija del ex ser
vicepresidente de george w dick cheney
fue retirada de su cargo como presidente
de la conferencia del partido
republicano un cargo en el que se
impulsa la agenda política del partido
republicano en el congreso su oposición
al supuesto fraude electoral que todavía
argumenta donald trump y sus
señalamientos sobre la responsabilidad
del expresidente tromp en los ataques
del 6 de enero pues hicieron que su
propio partido la retirara del cargo el
voto en contra del isstey ni muestra la
influencia que mantiene donald trump
sobre los congresistas republicanos
manda además el mensaje de que no puede
haber oposición alguna hacia el
exvicepresidente hacia el ex presidente
pero don donald trump porque como dicen
varios analistas acá en washington se
tiene que mantener el apoyo al ex
presidente para asegurar la victoria en
las elecciones legislativas del 2022
tras la votación en contra del isstey ni
pues está dijo que para ganar las
elecciones sin embargo hay que reconocer
ya la derrota
corregir lo que se hizo mal y tratar de
ganar las próximas elecciones agregó que
no se puede apoyar al mismo tiempo una
gran mentira como es el fraude electoral
que argumenta donald trump y también la
constitución y lo que eeuu necesita un
partido republicano fuerte y que ella
hará todo lo posible para evitar que
donald trump llegue a la casa blanca
nuevamente y para el cierre del
informativo veamos que tenemos en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom a
esta hora tenemos en portada más de 60
muertos dejar la escalada entre hamás e
israel es la misma noticia con la que
estamos abriendo este informativo allí
hay análisis y actualización en torno a
este tema es todo por el momento aquí en
france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]